okay billboards in san francisco and los
angeles warned against moving to texas
by invoking
mass shooting okay
by invoking mass shooting i don't even
know if this is legal to do that like
it can you really do something like this
as a campaign but let's let's read this
okay so
this is a new york post store if you can
put up the picture so people can see it
mysterious new billboards
are warning california residents not to
move to texas as record numbers of
residents flee the soft on crime golden
state for better
quality of life in red states the texas
miracle died in uvalde don't move to
texas that's actually the billboard
just look at that right there the texas
miracle died in uvalde don't move to
texas the billboard reads alongside a
hooded figure and a crossed out don't
mess with texas slogan the texas miracle
refers to former governor rick perry's
description of the state's regulatory
model which helped it weather the great
recession don't mess with texas a
favorite model in the lone star state is
rooted in the 1980s anti-littering
campaign when you see something like
this tom what do you think about
i think that if you and i put a
billboard up going the other way we
would be picketed we would be canceled
we would be attacked can you imagine if
we went the other way
point one point two
this is boogeyman politics you have
nothing good to say about yourself so
just point and say ew
and that
and that's all they're doing it's
they're trying to get you to stay
to stay in something
bad
by making something else look better
yeah exactly
not saying hey here's what we're going
to do for californians is we're doing
for business opportunity for education
we're going to do foreign highways
nope adam do you have thoughts on this
yeah of course yeah of course i mean we
you know
obviously uvalde is the hot topic right
now but you know mass shootings are not
unfortunately anything new in this
country but you know politically you
might have to have a short memory to not
find the irony here because not too long
ago in 2015
there was a san bernardino shooting a
mass killing right mass shooting where i
think a dozen people died yeah
right when you play politics like this
just be careful what comes out on the
other side now i'm not sure if you saw
what gavin newsom has been saying his
political ads have you seen any of these
lately
so um
i went down the rabbit hole and i did
you see uh um
ron desantis's air force ad top gov okay
top gov sick okay little
little hokey to me a little cringy and i
was like all right cool you got he put
his kid in there i get it all right and
then i saw gavin
gavin newsom's ad
and i just like threw up in my mouth i'm
not a california guy i don't give two
shits about gavin newsom
but i just know like what's a decent ad
what's not i gave like
the uh ron desantis had like a c minus
and then i saw the gavin newsom ad and i
think it was on july 4th and i was like
how do people not feel the fakeness oh
god of this guy i'm going to read you
what he basically had to say and you
just let me know what he he says it's
independence day and i mean when i talk
about as like
suit as like just phony and fake ha it's
independence day so let's talk about
what's going on here in america
freedom is under attack
in your state right republican leaders
they're banning books they're making it
harder to vote restricting speech in
your classrooms even criminalizing women
and doctors i urge all of you living in
florida and i was like hey i'm living in
florida what you got going on here buddy
i want you to join the fight and join us
in california well we still believe in
freedom i'm thinking god how out of
touch
is this freaking guy he's gone and how
does he keep getting elected and his
voice will you have to do the batman
yeah
it's just you've seen uh what's it uh
american psycho with uh christian vail
yeah that is gavin newsom to me that is
and here's a guy who's never had a real
job here's a guy that's never had to
work a single day in his life in a free
market in this you know enterprise side
to see how tough it is and making
decisions for them and uh
annoying a bunch of different people but
i will tell you what i think about this
ad here's what i think about this ad i
love it
i love it
let me tell you why
do you remember about six podcasts ago
when i said if i was if i was the
governor of florida
i would say the following
if
you want great entitlement programs to
move to california
if you want
to have your kids
have the ability to get the medicine to
have sex change you know whatever
transgender
if you want that move to the following
states california mm-hmm if you want
that third
move to california i love it you know
why i love it there's a part of me
that's using humor and sarcasm to almost
make your point it's not even used in
humor it's straight up facts so for them
to do this i love it because if a person
like me who's sitting there
and that's my state i'm gonna say what
the hell is this guy talking about i
don't relate to you i gotta go find a
new state to take my family where i feel
safe and quite frankly i don't feel safe
yesterday i got a text from jedidiah she
was a new york guy
i'm sure she had a great time she didn't
recognize that
difference
and she says
within nine hours while she was in new
york okay
she saw two crimes right in front of her
okay
she encountered a man walking around
naked creepy man walking around naked
okay vinnie and i go to new york i mean
he says she says i want to know where
adam went when he visited and did you
guys have him blindfolded
so maybe jed if you see something say
something maybe next time you guys got
to go to new york together
i feel like if you're looking for
something you're going to find it i walk
miles around new york i freaking love
new york but if you're like if you're
looking to find something weird in new
york believe me you'll find it well did
you hear what the new york governor said
about republican what did she say did
you hear what she said republicans
aren't welcome here get on a bus and go
down republicans aren't welcome here get
on a bus and go to florida bye and they
by the way and they criticize us for
living in an echo chamber apparently the
right has this giant echo chamber that
they can't get out of apparently she
doesn't have a spreadsheet because
that's going to increase the deficit in
her listen talk all the smack you want
about gavin newsom don't get it twisted
this guy is a frontrunner for the
democratic i don't disagree he will be
running
and he could very well win did you did
you see him uh in the interview when he
was like i'm telling you i'm not running
i don't know what other way to tell you
i am a governor i love this state
then the guy says then why are you
talking about all these national issues
well because that's important i love
this country this is my country's yeah
but you sound like you're running i'm
not running can you say right now on
camera you're not going to be running
i'm not going to be running for i'm
telling you i'm not it was a very
the interviewer did a fantastic job
pushing him on it to the point where he
was getting pissed so by the end of it
if you watched it
you would have said he's not running i
posted on the instagram post this means
he's running because he's obviously do
you think gavin newsom will end up
running
uh i'm the president i'm saying 70
oh i'm way higher than that
i was going to say because the last time
i was on here you showed that he was he
was uh with the shirt white shirt ty
walking in the white house lawn while
biden was and the only reason i said 70
is because when i was in california
somebody shared with me some things
about him
that is spreading that is why he doesn't
want to run because he doesn't want that
to come out okay now how much
credibility that has i don't know
anything the person that said it has
credibility but the person that told him
i don't know that person so it's like
adam telling me his best friend said
this but i don't know who's best so
without him without him running let's
say gavin newsom yeah
biden says he's going to run who do you
guys think is going to be who would be
their front runner if newsom because i
think newsome is the presidential look
that they would go for
bernie yeah according to favorability
ratings it's burning burning people
unless unless hillary gets
involved i think i think the democratic
field is wide open right now yeah wide
open
i'll go back to the same point i made uh
10 podcasts ago
the dnc
is shadowing
all of these stories that are coming out
on biden and you have the soft negative
story in the new york times in vanity
fair all these on biden is it time
you know and it's like the it's like
is it time to say goodbye to good old
joe is that it you see all those soft
articles they're every week there's a
new one yeah there's articles that
aren't even that's off they're just like
time to go joe yeah bye-bye grandpa
that's cnn did that msnbc did that
so as soon as
the dnc behind closed doors
clicks the stopwatch it starts
that's where the money is the money to
run a national campaign is with the dnc
coffers that is the soros money that's
the big stacks
you have to raise campaign money but the
big gunpowder is with the dnc so the dnc
has not yet said
we are going to primary this president
but when they do
it is a wide field
but bernie
gavin and they're all going to have the
same thing well
we got together as a political party and
it's too important and this is too
important so i am running because it's
too important and that's what they'll do
once they
have a solution
for
the biden step aside and they're going
to do it elegantly
but until that time
he is the
pin cushion
that all of this controversy attracts
and so let him take all the heat on this
why put a front runner out there and let
them get beat up a little bit right now
right yeah and you wait till after
midterms if i was at dnc
this is exactly the way i'd be playing
it hmm
i just if i was burning though right now
i'd be like you guys
screwed me over how many times i'm not
doing this [ __ ] again every time i don't
think i don't see bernie running well
just because just because the dnc is
done with bernie doesn't mean the people
are done with bernie yeah true well
that's correct people the people still
want bernie but
i don't know when he talks about the
liberals that you know that's bernie
sanders right the huh
this doesn't talk he talks like this and
this lip doesn't move that's actually
just fantastic
it's actually very good right hey i
don't talk
like this as long as this is numb like
you went to the dentist
like you got numbed up so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]